humdrum boring this meeting should have
been an email
dry
when can we leave phrases like this
right ideally
don't come up
or are not used to describe a gathering
or conversation in this video we're
gonna unpack how to create humor
in conversation i really love to laugh
if you're not good at humor or you don't
identify as a funny person you'll love
this video if you are a humorous person
and you are a funny person you'll love
this video because i'm going to unpack
the science behind it if you hate humor
and think it doesn't have a place in
conversation or work or life
don't watch this video please i'm chad
littlefield i'm the co-founder of we and
me and the creator of this connection
toolkit
and one core aspect to connection is
humor it's one of the ways that we
relate
let's get into it
[Music]
they say
that laughter is the best medicine is
that the phrase actually okay well i'll
just google it i'm not really sure if
they say that laughter is the best
medicine but i'm saying right now that
laughter is great medicine and in this
video i'm going to share comedian
secrets on how to create some humor and
also the science and art behind humor
robert provine at the university of
maryland uh found with his uh research
team that people tend to laugh 30 times
more when they are with people than when
they are alone and for me this is
points toward the importance of humor in
connection right we tend to laugh with
you now there are lots of reasons for
that and also laughter is not synonymous
with humor right you can think
something's really funny and be deadpan
and not laugh you can also laugh and not
think something is funny one of my
teachers jeff falls used to say that
laughter is nervousness leaving the body
and since he said that i cannot stop
thinking about that every time somebody
laughs i'm like are you nervous or you
actually think that was funny right so i
think there's there's different types of
laughter i've come to understand that
there are different types of laughter
but oftentimes laughter with people is a
like
it's like a nervous chuckle even if it's
boisterous laughter it's
helps fill that awkwardness right i just
got back from a little mini family
reunion with some family i haven't seen
in many years and
there was a ton of laughter
most of it was very genuine like happy
to be back together with each other some
of it was like
we haven't seen each other for a while
and so let's just like say something
goofy everybody laughs and it releases
this tension right it's like nervousness
leaving or if it's nervousness leaving
the body it's tension leaving a group
the second piece of the science of uh
humor is i wish that i could find the
source i tried really hard before
hitting record but i was reading a book
that was
about comedy and about the science
behind comedy and in it they had a graph
and i have not been able to find this
graph so i don't even know if this is
rooted in data or not but the visual was
extremely useful to help me understand
what humor actually is if you picture
just a simple y-axis and x-axis the
graph of humor that they uh that was in
this book that i can't remember
went like this i did find some science
on it i'll share some ridiculously
academic language with you but it's
essentially humor is where
something is going one trajectory so
picture a line going like this and you
expect that line to continue because the
brain the human brain wants to
extrapolate what's happening next so
saying okay this is we're going this way
going this way we're going this way
we're probably going to go this way and
humor and lacto happens when the story
doesn't go that way it takes a turn for
something different the research that i
found on this so you get the idea right
you probably don't need any more than
that to understand that humor is when we
think something's going one way and it
doesn't i have a really fun example to
share with you but the academic language
of humor is the juxtaposition of
incompatible concepts it's like okay
right two things don't go together and
you put them together in a way and it
was surprising and that created some
humor or laughter one really concrete
example that i've been trying to master
lately are dad jokes right so what is
the leading cause of dry skin
towels this is like
terrible joke um but it was not the
answer you expected now with that one
like you might not have expected any
answer but you were probably thinking
about like
some skin disorder or like dry
temperatures or something else right you
weren't thinking about
what was funny about that was the fact
that you weren't expecting something so
obvious and literal if you've ever come
across anti-jokes before this is a
perfect example of how the trajectory of
something is going one way and then it
takes a deep dive turn for something
else so for example uh what's worse than
finding a whole worm in your apple
breaking your leg
it's like
yes okay what's worse than finding a
whole worm in your apple is of course if
i'm extrapolating it's finding a half of
a worm in your apple but when you go
anti-jokes the idea that you're
something so incompatible and juxtaposed
that it's popped in and
now a caveat with this some people find
anti-jokes funny some people do not i've
learned that i happen to be somebody who
appreciates anti-jokes feel free to
leave one in the comments if you want to
make me laugh the third way and maybe
the more practical way this can show up
in conversation is through story so if
you're subscribed to the ch if you're
subscribed to the ch if you're
subscribed to the channel uh you may
have heard me share the story about the
girl with tattoos
all over her neck and in that story
right you expect that story to go one
way and when it doesn't
and i have uh told this story to many
thousands of people in person uh in live
audiences or or remote audiences and
every single time it creates
quite a whole heap of laughter and the
reason is that story takes a turn that
people weren't expecting it also happens
to be at my expense too which probably
starts to dip into the art of humor some
of the stuff that's not necessarily
rooted in data or science that we don't
totally understand but we know
contributes to
something being funny or humorous which
speaking of let's shift gears completely
into the art of humor the first thing is
energy
this used to really frustrate me but the
most common feedback that i would get
after leading a workshop
giving a keynote or even just a
one-on-one mentoring or coaching call
with a client almost every single time
somebody would come up to me and say oh
chad let's just love your energy and
they used to frustrate me because i was
like what do i do with that feedback
like i don't know what that is
and then i realized
that is
an essential element to why people laugh
at a story that i tell or why people are
really present when i lower my voice
it's my energy
is eeking out of my pores i can't help
it maybe much to my wife's dismay at
five in the morning when i wake up and
i'm feeling energy for life now i don't
wake up every morning at 5am feeling
like that but um the point is your
energy is it's not something that we've
scientifically been able to point at
energy's a little bit of a ethereal word
but you know it matters right i met my
wife living on a anishinabe indian
reservation in northern minnesota
on this trip for a month and there were
these two medicine men one of the names
richard morrison and he walked into the
room and i've got a little bit of add
adhd
he walked in the room and whatever
energy brought in with him was just
i was brought down to the ground and i
sat still
and listened for four hours straight
as he talked he just had this energy
that just commanded a presence in aroma
change the dynamic some people have that
energy
that contributes to humor so again it's
the art i don't have a specific tip or
directive here other than to tune into
what energy you're giving off if you're
giving off a uh all business
monotone energy
no one's gonna laugh when you make a
joke right unless you're in britain
maybe the second note on the art of
humor is around sarcasm will my
co-founder introduced me to this idea
that sarcasm in the original greek
actually means to tear flesh and i need
to fact check everything so of course i
fact check that and it actually means to
tear flesh like a dog
and so
as somebody who tends to
be drawn towards sarcasm it's really
forced some introspection for me of
how useful that is for people versus
when it's at somebody else's expense
versus when i could create humor through
another pathway if somebody comes up to
me and i sarcastically say oh you look
really nice today
or oh nice hair
right
i am tearing them apart in that
and it's just uh hidden with this
culturally acceptable
thing we call sarcasm
and so part of the art of humor is being
really mindful will takes a stance he
says no sarcasm i don't take such a hard
stance i think sarcasm is fine if it
serves a purpose and is at nobody else's
expense
um or even if it's a little bit
self-deprecating i'm cool with that too
i think the best way to alienate
yourself from a group or a conversation
or an audience is to put yourself on a
pedestal someone who always succeeds
makes it everything works out just fine
as opposed to being like oh my goodness
you have no idea there's like stumbling
through the world failure after failure
learning some things as we go okay last
bit combining the art and science of
humor and i'm really really excited
about this one
i
want to get better at humor and so i
would love for you to comment below with
what you think creates humor in a
conversation in theory the longer this
video is on the internet the more useful
the comment thread will get i'm chad
littlefield i hope this helped you as a
leader or an educator make connection
engagement easy
have an awesome day